ig o jornal tabaco mas tenho que jogar
com vocês eu gosto muito de animal
sempre gostei de animal crescido em
campo e mal a muita coisa que tenho
raiva sob aquele cachorro que você fica
brincando com ele na bola no rabo
ele vai avançando rápido ele vai
balançar no rádio e na hora que você vai
ficar nele cachorrinhos a thamara também
tem honrado aquele cachorro que aparece
do nada quando eu vou tocar a campanha
levou a sair correndo da cena política
tem cachorro é avisada que faltou a
campanha mas sempre tem aquele time que
tem um cachorro gigante na casa dele é
você fala assim a palha cachorro móvel
faz nada não faz cachorro a ninguém não
o cachorro ta com aquela cara de festa
armado não falou que me mordeu claro que
nunca que mordeu animal é o dono pois é
algumas semanas atrás eu visitei a
fundação a pipa que a associação de
proteção aos animais eles cuidam dos
animais é que eles fazem enquanto os
animais na rua em situação de risco
animais que foram abandonados na rua
maltratado pelos antigos donos e cuidam
e lá encontrei essa belezura kim e
américa a eliminar 18 mudado de vale oi
oi oi o mundo o mundo foi muito linda
moça tornava muito na van
a mulher é uma de quatro irmãos ou
infelizmente não por trazer mais porque
é muito pequeno
o tópico funciona assim o tio animais da
rua curió e coloca a doação tocar que
isso seja movimentado é preciso que
vocês adotem os animais a gente falar
'eu não adota um animal porque eles
sabem demais sinto na sede do pib foi
porque até onde eu sei quanto é pequeno
cágado pra [ __ ] de carga e cara muito
né vamos de carga muito né sic e uma
criança de 4 e vão crescendo vão se
acostumando aprendendo a mas não gosto
de dar muito trabalho sabe que ainda há
trabalho ser humano você tem um amigo e
menti pra você e das costas quando você
precisa ter posto em directo face
o que agora quer um amigo de verdade
adote um animal não menti pra você ficar
com você quando você está triste quando
você está feliz não tem facebook medo no
pv ele ainda é mais bonito que todos os
seus amigos néné é mais bonito que todos
meus amigos então se você aqui teresina
visite a pipa tudo que você quiser saber
o endereço a hora que você pode estar
aqui na descrição do vídeo se você é de
outra cidade de outro estado vai alguma
instituição que ajude mais perto da sua
casa e adote um animal porque já faz
algumas semanas que eu tenho mulher e eu
posso afirmar com toda certeza pra vocês
eu não repita bené fica feliz da minha
vida brinca só de pensar que ela poderia
estar na rua agora passando fome ou ou
alguma coisa do tipo já fico triste
quando você tá deste país o animal
sempre sabe que você está triste bailar
animar quando você tá só veio brincar
com você
então é isso
muito obrigado por cento este ano e meio
até aqui bem gostei de você tiver o
estado se inscreve no canal mas enquanto
tiver pique novo você sabe como é que
embaixo nome do seu animal se você tem
um caso você tem um cachorro quem mais
gosto de fazer e é isso aí
homero da al qaeda já